they confronted both or two guards who
immediately opened fire all of the
sudden all hell broke loose the spread
of illness and the spread of disease
it's almost a certainty this is a
humanitarian crisis guaranteed to be an
absolute disaster
[Music]
Mexico is the country that is basically
moved through by people coming from
Central and South America as well all
moving trying to get to the United
States to claim asylum there but
becoming quite small numbers they
usually smuggle through with gangs and
it's very very dangerous so much so that
as a concept grew it where people would
gather together and go on mass and it's
a safety of numbers thing and they
became known as the caravan
no one had seen this before there were
thousands and thousands of people and it
was a remarkable sight there's
incredible shot from above where you can
actually see the scale of the caravan
we hadn't before seen this movement of
thousands of people moving as one
walking as one the caravan became focal
point because there were these pictures
of large numbers of people heading
towards the United States on foot often
through jungles swimming through rivers
what was a striking phenomenon was that
there were you know lots of men and
women but about half of them were
children many others children actually
born on the caravan absolutely one who
explains of desperation is when you're
at full term pregnancy and you still
start walking to the United States
thousands of miles and have your baby on
the way
it's difficult to imagine how desperate
things can be the countries where
they're coming from in Central America
there's terrible gang violence people
are pressed to join the gang if they
don't families are murdered and poverty
as well no jobs absolutely broke and
ultimately that is what they're trying
to escape from they were traveling with
this assumption that actually America
would open its arms and say you know you
can come in early on President Trump
made it clear that wasn't going to
happen
you think we're letting that Caravan
come into this country you could
together person Trump said you know
these are criminals
these are people coming to America to
take our jobs these are people who are
just looking for new economic
opportunities there's nothing to do with
the silo this has to do with getting
into our country illegally was very
clear right from the beginning that as
they got nearer he was going to say
we'll close the border completely we
have to they might as well turn back
they're not coming into this country he
didn't really matter what their claim
was going to be then we're never gonna
be get given a good reception
they're still kept coming what was
interesting nobody knew where they were
going to go you know the border is maybe
two thousand miles long the assumption
was that Tijuana would be the best place
which is right next to San Diego you
know it's one of the busiest crossing
points there isn't in the United States
the striking thing to me about to honor
certainly the coastal area is the border
wall fence that goes across the beach
and into the water
[Music]
we even walk around it at low tide but
of course the border police could have
pick it up straight away
it's a very odd concept to stare at this
fence across the beach and go out there
San Diego and here's to honor
there's the dream and here's just short
of your dream the United States is
increasing security along this border
fence and it's quite likely that more
people will attempt to cross illegally
the point to remember though is that the
vast majority of the migrants don't want
to cross illegally they don't want to
break laws they want to claim asylum
[Music]
they just truly believe that once they
go to Tijuana and once the u.s. Border
Patrol saw them they would go yeah
you're right
you do need help
[Music]
it was a sort of guaranteed to be a
chaotic arrival because there was
nowhere for them to go the facilities
couldn't cope with thousands of
thousands of people and families who
needed care and eventually the local
authority found them a Sports Center
with a baseball field where they built
makeshift shelters as best they could
the most vulnerable most ill were put
inside the Sports Center itself and they
put up a few portaloos and showers now
that was it when they first started
arriving there was one organized
demonstration against them which came to
a sort of standoff with the police man
immigrant this is an invasion of our
country it's going the protesters had
actually come down to the camp and riot
police had to be sent in and separated
the protesters from the migrant Caravan
members
this is what the authorities here have
been concerned about there is a real
possibility of violent clashes between
protesters in the city
perhaps the migrants themselves and of
course the police stuck in the middle
the information we put out there was one
the painted migrants in an unfair light
that they were all criminals and people
were genuinely afraid also the people
came endearment is bad people of course
it's good
of course people don't say we don't want
all these people coming here and God
knows what disease I've got and they're
all gonna rape our women take our jobs
that I think was what was behind this
demonstration this anger towards them if
you actually go to these camps and meet
these people it's very clear but that
just simply isn't true I mean there's a
large number of children families to say
that they're all criminals it's just
plainly unfair
I saw a woman and her partner and a
small baby he come through the doors of
the gymnasium
their names were Juan and oh Linda and
that was their baby named Juana she'd
been born just a few days before the
caravan set off at that stage she was
about 6 weeks old and she had a little
bit of a cough
we heard a bit more about this story and
it was a very sad story her brother was
a gangster
he killed at least one person maybe more
and was involved in the murders of many
other people she had actually turned him
in to the authorities and it had
basically put a target on her back the
gang were after her the authorities said
you have to leave the country we cannot
look after you they were a classic case
of people who said that they would hope
to get asylum and so they found
themselves in this gymnasium with loads
of other families and their small babies
but when you have so many people living
together in a concentrated space the
spread of illness and the spread of
disease that's almost a certainty
there's always more people arriving
there's always more people coming and so
this was just a continuous deteriorating
situation
one night several bus loads ride and I
went to town that morning into film and
I could sense that it was noticeably
different conditions were just
deteriorating very quickly we were
talking to the medical staff there
trying to help there and they're saying
this is a humanitarian crisis now that
they're in take quarters that's where it
could actually get scary they were
adults who are ill next to little
children that was just guaranteed to be
an absolute disaster and quite quickly
we noticed people coffee
people didn't look very well at all or
particularly the little ones
[Music]
we then went back to the gymnasium to
try and find baby honey and her parents
we rang them and said Lola we were not
in a camp
we've been emergency evacuated to local
hospital because one as health has
deteriorated
Varner had been put into intensive care
in the hospital and there was no way
that we were going to get into that
hospital to film her because you can't
just have strangers walking into a
pediatric ward so we spoke to on his dad
one and bequeath when I see how your
daughter is and we said can you go and
film it for us
we came out with pictures of his
daughter at mid breathing apparatus and
looking tiny and very vulnerable and
really poorly when I first saw the
picture that I thought well I hope she
makes it there just to see a young baby
like that inside an oxygen tank
essentially it's quite worried at the
same time I think we all thought thank
god she's getting some treatment because
it had she stayed in that camp I don't
think the story would have ended waited
[Music]
a few days later panic started
responding to the drugs and she was able
to leave the spread of illness and this
level of Sanitation is just not viable
for people to live in for an extended
amount of time and Quanah became
symbolic of that it's not cushy for the
migrant caravan they're not living it up
in the Sports Complex camp they're
living in very difficult conditions
[Music]
on one of the nights there was very very
heavy rain
we went there the next day and people
were just miserable as clothes hang to
dry everywhere it was rubbish strewn
everywhere the poor soluz and the
temperatures just clogged up they were
just disintegrating in front of our eyes
by this stage more people from the
migrant Caravan had arrived so the camp
was even fuller at first it was
contained within the Sports Complex it
had now overflowed onto the street
the last 24 hours the atmosphere has
completely changed there are a lot more
people this is a food queue it's being
provided by the Marines it's going to
take ages to get fed the camp is packed
I am not sure that this is sustainable
people just won't stay here living in
these conditions at some point somebody
is going to say we have to get out of
here because this is just too dangerous
[Music]
slowly we started to see people leaving
they walked toward the US border things
have changed here much more quickly to
be expected people are saying enough
Sanaa they're not criticizing anyone in
Mexico they're saying that the camp
isn't set up to look after this number
of people and so they're they're leaving
[Music]
they were very soon stopped from getting
anywhere close to the border by a row of
riot police that was blocking off the
bridges
[Music]
the Mexican police themselves had
realized these people were mainly
families they had no desire to have a
fight
[Music]
it's always gonna be a little bit
jarring to see a right police you know
in full gear with their shields and
their helmets on you know looking quite
mean and you know three four or five
year old sort of playing around their
feet
who's generally a very peaceful
atmosphere but all of the sudden all
hell broke loose
a group to the right of the bridge
suddenly broke free of the riot police
[Applause]
and this just escalated I mean it spread
like wildfire all of a sudden everyone
was pushing through suddenly there are
literally thousands people just running
pastures
let's say this is two somewhat chaos it
now they've actually got through the
police lines they're running now towards
the border
there was complete chaos there is no
stopping anyone and the riot police was
completely overwhelmed and I just
thought this is it
a certain bunny and you can't really
tell what's going on at first the sprint
for boredom is not a direct print it was
under a bridge up a little hill down
into huge sewage ducts what I ompletely
remembered was just how steep the
embankment some reasearch canal were you
could have running down them I mean they
were very very steep and it was very
difficult to maneuver it down the canal
[Music]
Ouiser so the stream of sewage and
there's a small bridge where they all
filed across and I'm of filming as of
almost falling in everyone sort of
pushing and shoving just to get across
there's people without any shoes on
carrying everything they had carrying
their children
all the way along you would see that
families sort of all helping each other
up
they were running with their strollers
they were running with their backpack I
[Music]
don't think they knew what they were get
to do I didn't know what they didn't I
thought are they gonna charge at the US
border because this could potentially
quite dangerous Donald Trump had said
that he would fire on anyone that tried
to cross the border
I think when they got to the fences when
they actually realized hang on this is
not just a matter of going up to the
fence and saying we're here because the
reception from the other side was not
friendly
[Music]
when we looked through the fence you
could see us all patrol who are on the
other side who are armed not what the
migrants thought might be their welcome
I noticed a small group climbing up on
the fence and they've found it a weak
point and they were kicking at it
they were able to push their way through
for the first time that people started
going across and there they were they
had made it into the United States put
the hands in the air and surrendered
themselves they would have been arrested
but the asylum process would have
started for them
they confronted the border guards who
immediately opened fire
[Applause]
[Music]
they were met with tear gas and they
were met with rubber bullets also
falling over themselves running away
from this gap one or two of the younger
men started throwing stones
that is pretty much the end of their
luck that was just the worst image you
could ever have tear gas being fired
people have actually broken through the
barricades there were a lot of children
in the migrant caravan as we saw then
suddenly they were yanked into this
chaotic and violent scenario and they
were obviously just following their
parents but they followed them into tear
gas as I was walking back I saw this
mother and her child they were crying
and realized that this boy had Down
syndrome and he'd been tear-gassed by
the Americans
he was obviously clearly disorientated
and extremely upset by it all as were
their family
I felt slightly uncomfortable about
filming that image to be honest it was
very vulnerable I felt like it was
it's almost exploiting it was
demonstrative of a group characterized
as criminals clearly anything but
an image can be very powerful it can be
powerful for good and it's important to
document these things
images of that boy went round the world
and it resulted in him being given
asylum in the United States he has been
allowed inside because he was seen on
television
as much as I felt bad for these families
the thought that they would just go
there and be let in was very naive
slowly people started to walk back down
along the train tracks and they just
stopped entirely entirely dejected
I cannot imagine how disheartening that
would have felt for people who decided
that that journey web journey of months
on foot just wasn't worth it
I think that was pretty much the
beginning of the end of the caravan to
try and get to the States was always an
impossible dream
we knew it the next day when there were
groups of people saying we're going home
and they had gone to the Mexican
authorities and said can you get us back
down to the border with Guatemala
if the Americans didn't want them and if
the local residents in Tijuana didn't
want them then what was the point in
staying anymore
people are going to keep trying to go to
the United States that is not going to
stop people have migrated now for
centuries it's it's what humans do to
escape violence or to find best lives it
isn't the United States responsibility
to just take everyone one has to accept
that that's the case
or every rich country would have
everyone just come in and knock on the
door but these that happen is that the
the countries where they're coming from
need to get sorted out and assessments
should be given to those countries from
the United States if necessary and
others to help calm those problems
there's extreme poverty there's also
extreme violence and so those that are
going back to the gang neighborhoods
that they've tried to flee who knows
what might happen to them you have to
look after people the responsibility to
look after anyone attending asylum or as
a refugee it's just about well if the
same happened to me would I hope
somebody would look after me I would
hope so and I think that's what I
suppose those people hoped as well
[Music]
you
[Music]